will start our last speaker of the
morning is Andre bogdanov of University
of Ottawa take it away Andre
thank you very much Ryan and thanks to
the organizers for inviting me to this
wonderful Workshop I was lucky to be
selected for something called
administrative processing so I couldn't
make it but I hope to catch up with some
of you perhaps later in the semester if
you're still around so this is I'm going
to be talking about joint work with alun
Rosen and it's not very much of a metal
talk but it is it does relate to average
case complexity and a bit of
cryptography perhaps
so I want to start at the very beginning
right where complexity theorists and
when we teach complexity in seven grades
this is what we teach right there is T
there is NT and then the result right
and okay so then we talk about all these
other wonderful things like click and
subset sum and vertex cover and they all
happen to be the same as set right so
that's so it's a simple picture it's
nice and then the students usually
conclude that NP means not NP means not
P right that's that's what the picture
it's consistent with the picture and
actually we have to work pretty hard to
find things that are uh you know in this
space between NP and P which are not the
same as sat right and some of the people
in this audience did some of this
wonderful work and now we have such
examples that we can ponder about but we
really have to work hard to to do it to
find to find them
and I want to contrast this picture with
the distributional picture so average
case World which looks nothing like this
right so there we have like the analog
of Statistics is bounded halting problem
and living Theory from the 80s tells us
that you know we have something on top
that we should expect uh you know as a
basis for showing that things are hard
but we haven't been very successful at
finding reductions and you know
essentially we understand now that these
problems are really about we do have
some problems that are complete but
they're all essentially about Turing
machines right they're they're The Meta
stuff they are the metal problems but
then there's all these other things that
we care about right and they are kind of
isolated Islands in this landscape like
we cannot really relate them to one
another
um even though if we talk about a single
problem like that like depending on how
we pick the parameters it's not clear
how to relate one version of the problem
to another version so it's a lot of it
is a mess it's something that we don't
like to talk much about so so we don't
um and uh last year actually in 2021 I
was at the same Institute at this
wonderful program on statistical
inference and one of the highlights of
that program was this network of
reductions that is largely from work of
Brennan and bresler from 2020 where they
wanted to explain why some problems that
come from machine learning and
statistics exhibit computational
statistical gaps and what this means is
that the upside down
so well the way that we draw reductions
in complexity theory yes right we start
with the easier ones and we go to the
harder ones right they try the wrong way
but we cannot do anything about that so
so yes it is supposed to be upside down
and um and so uh the motivation for
their work is they try to explain why
some problems where you're trying to
learn from samples there are gaps where
if you're not given enough samples then
you can in principle learn statistically
but there are no efficient algorithms
and they developed this nice network of
reductions that well it's not perfect
but it shows that under some conjecture
they can actually explain where a lot of
these gaps come from and you know so
it's not exactly clear that there are no
reductions in the distributional world
they exist but it's much less clear when
we can expect to have them and when we
cannot expect to have them and as
complexity theories that is our job
right to explain what happens
so that's what complexity theory is
right if we want to show that a problem
a is no harder than problem B then we
have reductions right that's that's what
reductions are for uh but we also want
to sometimes explain why is it that we
don't have reductions right why is it
that two problems are of incomparable
hardness or one is not easier than the
other one and how do we show that like
what are the tools that we use for that
often give a model where p is VC and ASR
yeah so we need some kind of separation
or oracles right and I mean complexity
classes are sort of a good convincing
argument for doing that right so if you
have some class of problems a that you
know does not capture all of B then
showing that the problem is in a means
that there is no reduction
so um I mean in the worst case World
there are such questions such examples
right so we also maybe not in seventh
grade but in ninth grade in tenth grade
we say well you know we have this
factoring problem that people really are
interested in and it's not NP hard and
uh right and and why is it not NP hard
it's because there is this other plus
quantity right so uh it's it's in the
intersection so we don't expect it to be
NP hard and then you know there are
other examples this brick log shortest
vectors and so on and it's the same kind
of argument so we can actually use
complexity Theory to argue right why one
problem might be not farther than the
other uh so uh so so that's that's
that's what I want to focus about about
on on today and then so if we want to
kind of have a finer understanding of
this hardness
what happens there uh and but in the
average case world uh we don't use this
kind of
reasoning so much right maybe in
cryptography we do have some Oracle
separations but when we talk about this
kind of concrete problems and again like
some of these are really interesting
like a lot of you in the audience did
this really amazing works on mcsp mktp
they do have worst case to average case
reduction so we really want to know what
happens in this world but we don't
really have so many separations uh and
uh one I think very interesting
separation that that that does exist is
this from this work of hijacki men ofek
in 2006 where they showed that random
sat for certain parameters there is some
setting of parameters if you pick a
random set formula in the unsatisfiable
regime where you have more Clauses than
variables uh where uh we don't know how
to solve it so we don't know how to
algorithmically uh certify that it's
unsatisfiable but there do exist some uh
non-constructive witnesses that we we
can verify so they showed that set I
don't know it close to variable density
and to the 1.4 or something is actually
has an average case algorithm but it's a
non-deterministic algorithm right you
need to give it a witness and it only
works well on average right so uh I
think it would be nice to have more
examples of such such problems and more
natural examples uh you know not
necessarily to advance meta complexity
but just sort of to to play with I think
one of the arguments that you give that
mktp you know is nothing uh
right
uh you know we that reduce it from these
things like link or sets which which we
saw in the workshop but then we don't
expect to have reductions in the other
direction
uh and the problem I want to talk about
today is called the nearest Boolean
Vector problem so it's this simple very
natural problem which was introduced in
work by mohantin ragavindra and Shu in
2020. so the question here is uh we have
the Boolean Cube and dimensional Boolean
q and now I take some Subspace n
dimensional Subspace
uh linear Subspace and I want to
distinguish between two cases in digital
currencies are subspaces which are close
to the cube and the no instances are
subspaces which are far from the cube
and here when I say part of from the
cube I put this one half like so square
root of M is like the the you know the
the norm of the vertices of the queue
why did I put the square root one half
this one half here because what they're
really
instances is what happens when this a Is
Random
right and there is a natural
Distribution on subspaces right they can
pick a random and dimensional Subspace
and they actually argue that in some
natural setting of parameters which I
will explain why they're interested in
in a minute
um that most of spaces are like that and
actually it's not one half it's some
constant like I don't remember two over
pi over pi over two that they calculate
where they say that most subspaces where
the ratio I know over m is a
sufficiently small constant are actually
quite far from the Boolean Cube uh so uh
why are they interested in this problem
and the complexity of this problem uh
the reason they were interested in is
because of another problem that again
comes from uh
statistics I guess and uh
um optimization
and this is the question of optimizing
what they call the sherington
Kirkpatrick hamiltonian so this is
purely motivation it's not going to play
a role later in my talk but it's a very
nice question and it's a very
interesting connection so I want to tell
you about it so what is the sherington
Kirkpatrick uh uh hamiltonian so you're
given some Matrix M that is essentially
a random Matrix with real numbers random
symmetric Matrix with real numbers is
chosen from something called The
gaussian orthogonal Ensemble which
essentially says that I choose the
entries to be random normals independent
normal random variables uh condition
only being symmetric
and what this problem asks if it's to
optimize the
form X transpose MX where X itself is a
vector in the Boolean Cube
um and I think this was proposed back in
the 70s as some kind of model of spin
glass or something I don't know exactly
the history but it's an interesting
combinatorial problem in its own right
and uh it turns out that
uh this maximum for most matrices can be
bounded
and one way to bound it is to just
replace the Boolean cube with the ball
right so instead of optimizing over the
Boolean Cube I can optimize over all
vectors of a norm square root of M and
then what this quantity turns out to be
is just the largest eigenvalue of the
Matrix M and this is well studied for
random matrices and it turns out to have
uh value which concentrates around 2 m
to the three halves the scaling that I
used and what they're actually
interested in is not the same to the
three halves there is no mystery in that
but this constant two
okay uh and the reason it's interesting
is because it turns out that this two is
an overestimate it's not the right
answer
for uh for the for sharington
Kirkpatrick and this is a famous uh uh
constant called parisis constant but
what perisic conjectured and then
Telegraph later proves is that the
actual value is something uh that is
strictly smaller than two one point five
two five to six uh actually I mean this
is only a special case of some
optimization problem that they looked at
this corresponds to the zero temperature
regime and what Parisi gave is the whole
formula for this which is very
mysterious and and this is a whole other
story but but but this is the this is
the motivation
um and what happened uh much more
recently and again this is something I
learned at the assignments is that uh uh
Montana algorithmic question right so
this is a fact which is true about move
matrices but if I give you a specific
Matrix uh What uh what is the complexity
of finding a solution to this problem
and in our language what he shows is
that there is an average case heuristic
algorithm so for most matrices it finds
a solution which has value close to this
Parisi constant 1.526
um so that's nice right but that's the
again complexity theorists were not
super happy with heuristic we want
something which has uh better guarantees
right and what's better to have a than a
heuristic is an actual uh an errorless
heuristic something that always gives
you the right answer but maybe you know
doesn't work on all instances sometimes
it can say I don't know and uh so okay
my slide is a bit messed up here but uh
What uh uh Mohan tiragavindra and shoe
or motivated by what's exactly this
question so they ask is there an
errorless heuristic for this algorithm
and the way that they uh try to
tackle this problem is by giving a
reduction from Sharing Center Patrick to
the nearest Boolean Vector problem
uh and it's not a difficult reduction
but it's outside the scope so I'm not
going to tell you what it is but what
the result essentially shows is that if
I can show that nearest Boolean Vector
is uh has airless heuristics or in other
words they had refutations right that in
the case when most of the instances are
hard they can certify that they're hard
that they don't have a solution uh for a
certain setting of parameters and the
setting of parameters they need I mean
is that where the
dimension the Relative Dimension is a
constant you can think of it as the rate
and the distance is also a constant
right so it's some fraction of the of
square root of M and if if you can find
refutations for for this nearest Boolean
Vector problem then you automatically
get certificate that sharington
chiropractic is well at least it beats
the spectral certificate of two it's a
little bit less than two maybe like 1.99
still far from Paris is constant but at
least is the first step that you would
have to do
um so that was what they first wrote in
the paper but then they gave
negative evidence so they said well how
do we and how are we going to find this
uh this heuristic this errorless
heuristic this refutation and well
they're going to use the sum of squares
algorithm which is what uh uh a common
algorithm for this kind of settings and
there what they proved is that some of
squares doesn't work actually it thinks
that if I give it a random Subspace not
only is it not far from the Boolean Cube
but it actually has a vector which is in
the Boolean Cube uh and there were some
technical improvements later on on the
parameter settings to which this applies
but the punchline is that kind of even
in the very extreme case of this problem
uh Samsung squares cannot distinguish
random subspaces from subspaces that
contain a Boolean Vector inside them
um so what is our results so what we
show is that
um even though uh we uh we don't have an
algorithm that at least there is some
regime of parameters so I will explain
what it is in which uh uh refutations do
exist and in fact uh this uh average
case problems is in average case
statistical zero knowledge so it's
somewhere inside uh NP intersect point B
right so the setting of parameter series
you should think about n divided by m uh
the rate that's being slightly less than
a constant so this is not this is close
enough to what they get and but what's
uh weaker in the result that we get is
that this parameter gamma which tells
you how the proximity to the hypercube
in the less instances is not a constant
but it's something that depends inverse
polynomially on all these parameters in
the problem
and excellent here is the fraction of
instances of which this algorithm is
going to fail so it cannot certify that
all subspaces are not in the Boolean
cube in fact that's an NP heart problem
but it can certify that all but uh
essentially one over two to the end of
the spaces are not execute
um so what I want to do for the rest of
the talk I want to tell you a bit about
how we came uh how how we stumbled upon
this result some connections to some
work that we uh in cryptography uh which
is the
more than 20 years old
and
um
yeah and then and then conclude with
some open questions at the end
uh yeah so a corollary of this work is
because we know statistical neurologists
in am intersect oam that we can actually
certify that if I give you a random
Subspace that it's far from the Boolean
Cube
um
so we get certificate interactive
certificates for this and again so this
is kind of like the same situation as
friends in the sense that this infracted
certificates exist but we don't know how
to compute them and I we don't right now
we don't see any reason to believe why
they should be efficiently computable
foreign
so to get you a sense about what this
certificates look like so I'm not going
to actually talk about SDK I'm just
going to try to tell you how would I
prove to you that the Matrix is far from
the Boolean Cube let me here are two
matrices so one of this is actually
close to the Boolean Cube and one of
these them is apart from the Boolean
Cube uh when I I mean the column space
of these two matrices so if I think of
the space generated by the two column
vectors one of them is random and one of
them actually has a point which is close
to the Boolean Cube uh does anyone have
a guess of which is which
okay hey
is the one which is close
okay yes well I mean okay this is this
is a bunch of numbers so we cannot see
it so let's plot them right so this is
the plot right these are the numbers and
actually I have to tell you that I
cheated here I didn't actually put
something that's in the movie and Cube
because that would be a bit too obvious
in two Dimensions but they still chose I
planted an integer Vector inside
something that has integral coordinates
like zero plus minus one plus minus two
right so again these are two sets of
points right and one of them has some
like belongs to like has some integer
Vector in the column space and the other
one doesn't
uh do you have a guest now about which
one might have the integer Vector inside
like do you see any lines here
not not clear right
so here is the idea the idea it would
happen if we take random plus minus one
combination so we hit both these
matrices A and B on the left with the
random plus minus one vector
and this is the picture that we get
right so this is just some kind of
distribution over vectors which is I I
hit the Matrix a with discrete vectors
on the left and I hit the Matrix B with
discrete vectors on the right
and now now you can kind of see where
the lines appear right Matrix a doesn't
have many lines but in Matrix B you can
now see like there is a line here and
there is a line here and there is a line
here and this exactly corresponds to the
direction I mean the orthogonal
direction of where the this planted
Vector was uh was put in I guess a
because it had too many Maya signs
[Music]
the minus signs that's actually I didn't
cheat I I I did it at random I did it on
the computer so you know that's that's
what Randomness looks like in real life
so uh okay so what does this have to do
with certificates right well how am I
now going to prove to you that the
Matrix is like a and not like B
and one way to prove to you like it is I
give you a random challenge I give you a
random Point somewhere and I ask you to
find me one of these plus minus one
combination which is close to it
and if I give you Matrix B then you have
no chance right if I choose my
parameters correctly because if I pick a
random point then
it's likely to fall between some of two
of these lines and then there will be
not nothing around it for you to to give
me
uh and what is a bit more interesting is
that if the Matrix a is chosen at random
then you can typically do this in some
sense if I take a random gaussian Matrix
and I take this plus minus one
combinations it's going to fill up space
evenly each one of the marginal
distribution of each of the points is
going to be gaussian but actually it's
going to be statistically close in some
sense to the gaussian distribution
and in what sense is it statistically
closed so this is the uh this is the
technical claim is that if I take a
normal Matrix a I hit it by a random
plus minus one vector on the left and
then I compare the output of this Matrix
to a gaussian vector condition on the
choice of a right so I fixed a and then
I compare the distribution x times a
with a gaussian vector that this should
be close to one another
they're not going to be close to one
another does anyone see why there they
cannot be close to one another
well one of the distributions is
discrete and the other one is continuous
right condition on a if I hit it with a
plus minus one vector on the left right
then what I get is just you know some
set of two to the two to the end points
right so it's a discrete distribution
well this is a continuous distribution
so these are going to be distinguishable
with probability one
but they don't know that if you do a
little bit of rounding then I'm not
going to tell you exactly what this
rounding is but it's quite insensitive
to the choice of parameters then these
two distributions do become statistical
exposed so really if you look at the
previous picture if I kind of you know I
round them appropriately then it does
look like what a rounded gaussian
uh and this is uh
um we proved this in a paper where we
talked where we were looking for
applications to this to public in
cryptography and uh describe some crypto
system based on this with uh Miguel
Quito novel and Sherwood swachmann and
along Rosen
um so okay so uh what is the implication
for this for the nearest Boolean Vector
well I would like to use this to certify
that the Matrix is random that is far
from the Boolean Cube
it works but unfortunately it's not
interesting okay or maybe fortunately no
but uh it it's not interesting the
reason it's not interesting is because
to make this result meaningful and it
turns out it's kind of a limitation of
this particular construction is that you
need to pick the dimension the number of
rows of the Matrix to be it has to be a
very tall Matrix and has to be bigger
than N squared
but when m is bigger than N squared then
the nearest Boolean Vector problem turns
out to be easy
okay so uh what is the nearest Julian
Victor problem easy for tone matrices
right it's because uh there is this uh
you know uh idea that's uh you know
again it's often used in crypto and also
in learning it's a linearization so uh
what do I what what are we looking for
we're looking for some kind of
approximate solution to this system of
equations I want to know if there is
some combination W of the column vectors
here that uh that will give me something
which is close to a plus minus one
vector and
I mean this is hard to solve with when
you're algebra because I don't know what
the designs are going to be whether
they're going to be plus one or minus
one but if I Square both sides right if
I do some kind of tensoring then I can
get a related equation where uh the
right hand side becomes just the old one
vectors so if I take the tensor of every
row of itself and the tensor of every of
w with itself then I get some some kind
of equation which is like a linear
equation right uh with with one on the
right hand side and if m is much less
than
um N squared right then this Matrix here
is still going to be have uh more
constraints and variables and I can I
can solve and figure out what w is going
to be so in other words the
nearest Boolean Vector to a Subspace
problem is not particularly interesting
when the number of rows is very large
and it's bigger than the square of the
number of points
so this is where like and even older
idea from cryptography program comes
from so there is actually a crypto
system of ITI and work which is better
than the one that
inspired that I told you about our word
just a minute ago which
essentially can be explained as a
similar idea but with one additional
twist which uh really helps improve the
parameters and the idea of ident work is
this so again think about it as I want
to I I have these two collections of
points and I want to know which one is
random and which one has some Boolean
Vector planted in the column space
so what I can work do is they single out
two of these points
and think of them as vectors so the
Black Point here is just the origin
right this is the old zero point and
then what they do is instead of uh doing
uh all these plus minus one combinations
over the reels they do everything modulo
uh this lapis which is generated by
these two vectors just some two two
points right so now the way that you can
think about it is this blue points they
follow in different parallel pipettes
but I'm going to work module of the
parallel pipeline so I'm going to kind
of put them all in the same one and then
see what happens to the distribution
and this is again the picture that we
get so this is what happens when I again
I take some kind of random plus minus
one combinations and then but now when I
do it modulo the parallel pipet so the
picture here is going to be just what
happens inside the parallel pipette
right so this these two axes are going
to be the two points that we chose
and you see that the left picture looks
pretty random the right picture looks
also a bit random but if you squint
really hard you can kind of still see
the lines right so there are some lines
here
but now they're they're noisier so it
looks like things are going in the wrong
direction for us right we don't see the
lines as clearly it turns out that's
true and there is a reason why it's
noisier but it has one big advantage and
so this is uh sort of this is this is
the way it looks algebraically their
construction so what they do is instead
of working with the Matrix a first they
cut out a square Matrix P out of it and
they think of this as the the parallel
pipette module which they're going to
work and then they're again going to
compare what happens to the two
distributions when I take a random
Matrix a and uh and and and I reduce the
these points modulo the parallel pipette
and what they prove is that it's going
to be very close to random now it's just
a distribution over a cube so it's going
to be uniform distribution
and the advantage is that here it's
actually going to be exponentially close
so the statistical parameter is much
much better than in the other
construction and it also works for the
value of M which is smaller so it works
when m is bigger than n log n uh the
disadvantage is that the construction
itself is more complicated so this is
you don't have to understand this but
they have to you know the algebra that
you have to do in order to you know put
these vectors in the parallel pipeline
is more complicated and that costs you
in in the completeness right that this
gamma parameters becomes larger because
somehow these operations increase the
noise
uh so that's so so that's
but that's essentially the idea uh so
one interesting kind of question that
came up in our in when we were doing
this is that uh in this in this
construction they have to use this
Matrix P inverse so it turns out that
when you want to calculate the
parameters to understand what happens to
gamma you need to understand uh like the
the the the distance from from the cube
right the the completeness error is
governed by it turns out what is the
largest eigenvalue of P inverse which is
the same thing as the smallest
eigenvalue of P so actually it shouldn't
say eigenvalue it should say singular
value so it should it should be this is
not a symmetric Matrix so it should
actually talk about singular value uh
and this is something which has been
studied so if I take a random Matrix of
a normals then it turns out that the
singular value is going to be with
constant probability no smaller than 1
over square root of n so this is the
factor that you're going to lose uh but
uh so we need to find inside this Matrix
a some kind of sub Matrix T which
doesn't have too small a singular value
so how do we do it well if the Matrix a
happens to be very big what we can do is
we can divide it in independent chunks
right everything is random and we can
say well at least one of these chunks
will have this property but then we have
to pay some Price Right the price we
have to pay is that uh the error like
the you know the the fraction of
instances for which the algorithm will
will fail is going to be somewhat large
right because we take this Matrix and we
partition it into a small number of
chunks right so the probability would be
something like uh if we do it in this
way sorry PowerPoint is acting up 2 to
the minus M over n roughly and what we
show is part of our analysis is that if
you do this in a greedy way so you add
the rules of P one by one According to
some Criterion then you can actually
improve this probability of finding a
matrix with a good smaller singular
value from 2 to the minus M over n to
something like 2 to the minus Omega of n
uh so that's that's a bit of an aside
but it's it's part of our analysis
um so uh so that's so so that's what we
do in the paper
uh so at least
like after after we did this uh some
some something that came to our mind and
uh and and uh yeah we we're still still
trying to understand and one um one
question natural question that you can
ask is well you know the sums of squares
algorithms right they don't see a
solution even in the case of perfect
completeness they cannot even detect the
random such space does not have a
Boolean point exactly inside it well is
it is that the real answer right if I
want if I'm if I given you a random if I
give you a random Subspace and I just
want you to prove to me that there is no
Boolean Point inside it then is this a
hard problem and it turns out it's not
it's actually an easy problem and this
goes back to uh ideas uh from uh where
people use what it is to solve subsets
some problems and in modern language
they can be actually created as a
reduction to the shortest Vector problem
in lattices so what this reduction is
tell us is that essentially well in the
perfect if I want to distinguish perfect
completeness from random then what you
can sort of cook up an instance of the
shortest Vector problem so that some
species that have a Boolean Vector in
them maps to instances with a very short
Vector while random subspaces mapped to
instances which have a very large Vector
inside and these two are actually
distinguishable in polynomial time by
the famous lll algorithm so this gives
us a polynomial time algorithm for
solving the exact version of npv even in
the case when m equals n plus one even
if I have just one more dimension
uh so now being a complexity theorist
like this touch your head and you think
well we know that SVP with very large
approximation Factor as a polynomial
time algorithm but actually we know more
we know that even if the approximation
factor is small we still can do
something right we have certificates
right and like for approximation Factor
M they're actually fairly simple
certificates but then like if you want
to push it then there is this again word
by atheronov and regep where they showed
that even approximation Factor square
root of them can be certified uh so uh
so perhaps what is happening here is
that you know
maybe one can obtain even better and
more efficient certificates using using
a direct reduction then going this
roundabout row through cryptography so
as I said it's inconclusive so but it's
still work in progress
um so let me finish a little bit early
uh well it's you can go to lunch but I
just want to uh to to to to to to to
leave you with with some some conclusion
and some open problems so I think sort
of the main
perhaps conclusion of this work is that
you know
this is an interesting problem because
again it's sort of there is these two
parameters which is the rate and the
distance and they seem to be they seem
to play a big role in the complexity of
the problem you know when you ship them
around you go from something which is
speed to something that has certificates
to something else that might uh you know
not be be inside the NP minus one p
average case NP minus one p uh and this
is something that is not fully captured
by the SOS lower bounds which is the
main methodology that people use to to
to to to to solve these kinds of
optimization problems uh so there might
be you know it might be some instance
where complexity has something
interesting to say about uh you know why
this SOS lower bounce or this uh
optimization methods might not give the
right answer
uh so I think the most interesting
question based on uh the motivation here
is whether the problem is in quantity
for kind of a more realistic setting of
parameters where both the rate and the
completeness error are custom some small
constants and that would relate to the
motivation of mohanti raghavendra and
Shu so if you could prove membership in
point P then you would get at least
non-deterministic certificates uh that
beat the eigenvalue Bound for the
Sharingan Kirkpatrick problem okay I
don't know if anybody outside complexity
Theory would be interested in it but at
least it's a nice story to tell and sort
of more ambitiously right because you
know as we move these parameters around
you get different behaviors then you can
start asking well is there some kind of
phase transition or you know does the
other thing happen where maybe if we
give the algorithm or the more time like
so we have like non-deterministic
sub-exponential time algorithms then we
can get even better parameters right and
I think something like this does happen
for the shortest Vector problem so it
might be related to that as well uh and
finally I think sort of the big agenda
or the thing that I'm interested in is
if we can find other more natural
examples of kind of problems in average
case complexity that are you know that
that's why in this interesting space
between NP and P right so they're not so
many right and I think all of the ones I
know have some something very
interesting happening in them there are
different features like this
uh
algorithm like really you know they
discover a new kind of combinatorial
structure that is used to to find the
witnesses so I think coming up with more
examples might be you know a good place
to go to understand a bit more what is
happening in average case complexity uh
so I will end here thank you
questions for Andre
[Music]
do you have a guess as to
whether
we be with these constant parameters
like whether you think it should be
endorphy or I think it shouldn't I mean
it looks like it shouldn't if you look
at the analogy with the shortest Vector
problem I think below like when n over m
is sub polynomial it shouldn't be but
again I mean it would be good to have
some evidence like for shortest Vector
problem at least there is some empty
hardness in the worst case that people
used to argue that you cannot solve
those kinds of problems here I think
even the worst case problem as far as I
know is not very well understood
so so I suspect that the answer is no
but I I don't know why like what would
you base the hardness on like that well
the first thing I would like to know is
the worst case version of this problem
right for this parameters is it NP hard
I don't know
this isn't a particularly like clear
question but you know it looks like
you're trying to relate this problem to
um to the last problems I'm wondering if
you've thought at all about Connections
to like planted plea
well I mean again like for the setting
of parameters that we looked at where
it's inside Point p as far as I know
planted click is outside right it's
outside quality so we wouldn't expect a
reduction from plant it quick to this
this if you can reduce the plant it
click I I have no idea right so I mean
it's a good question especially like in
this picture that I gave you right a lot
of okay so content quick is actually
important in in in in some of these
applications like if you if you can read
backwards it has the planted quick row
conjecture written down right so that's
the basis of all these reductions so in
fact if you can reduce anything too
quickly it would be very interesting I
think I mean they need some special
version it's not it's not like the usual
20th click they needed some
multi-partite graph and so on and so
forth but again I don't I don't know I I
don't see a planted quick structure like
average case kind of content quick
structure in here but who knows
yeah
any more questions
thank Andre one more time thanks
foreign